fahdawi a commencé à tirer en plein sur
les deux hommes qui j'ai tendait le bras
deux morts six blessés graves
c'est le bilan sanglant de la
confrontation du 14 février 74 entre
gendarmes et ouvriers agricoles sur
l'habitation chalvet à basse-pointe
selon plusieurs témoins environ 200
militaires appuyés par un hélicoptère
avait soigneusement encerclé les
grévistes avant d'ouvrir le feu et
protégé par les boucliers et ce drame
sera le point d'orgue du mouvement
agricole et des manifestations de ce
début d'année 1974 un an plus tôt une
sécheresse exceptionnelle a entraîné des
pertes très importantes dans le même
temps la hausse du prix du pétrole
engendrait une forte augmentation des
tarifs des denrées de première nécessité
pratiquement toutes importées
une crise dont les premières victimes
sont les ouvriers de la banane qui
constitue la main d'oeuvre la moins bien
payés de lille à l'époque un travailleur
deschamps est rémunéré 30 francs par
jour la grève entamée le 17 janvier
repose sur plusieurs revendications
comme une meilleure définition des
tâches la fin de l'utilisation des
produits dangereux dont déjà le fameux
kepone et surtout une revalorisation
salariale de 550 kg de lait par jour
huit heures de travail qu'on leur fait
ces transferts en car au lieu de travail
mais déjà abordé par la partie car la
culture et c'est ce qu'ils demandent je
vous le dis très simplement qu entre 69
cent soixante-treize ans 4 ans et demi
est à l'air ont passé de 17 francs par
jour à 30 francs après plus de trois
semaines de grève les négociations sont
au point mort
la dernière proposition des planteurs à
32 francs et catégoriquement refusée par
les syndicats qui décident de durcir le
mouvement
les ouvriers de la canne se déclare
solidaire
le rapport de force est engagée il faut
maintenant tenter d'enrôler un maximum
d'ouvriers en passant d'habitation en
habitation ces propos des chiens
présenter tes propos des chiens
travailleurs etc chacun la contestation
prend de l'ampleur et s'étend sur
l'ensemble de l'île rivière-pilote
lamentin robert romande sainte marie les
gendarmes
régulièrement appelé pour maintenir
l'ordre et suit généralement des jets de
pierres auxquels ils répliquent par des
tirs de grenades lacrymogènes
c'est dans ce contexte très tendu que
survient le drame de chalvet le préfet
aurait donné l'ordre d'employer tous les
moyens nécessaires pour mettre fin à la
révolte ouvrière dépêché à basse pointe
pour protéger une habitation
les gendarmes n'hésitent plus ils tirent
donc à balles réelles
les agendas augmenté admirer mais
j'étais dans la poule locaux voilà vous
voulez parler de ceux qui étaient
derrière nous derrière nous les tirs
contre les tirs d'ariane aux côtés qui y
voient un ouvrier agricole ne se relève
pas il manie serieys dire énorme avait
55 ans et était père de 22 enfants
l'émotion est considérable comme en
témoigne la foule rassemblée à ses
obsèques aux lorrains de jours plus tard
alors que le sentiment anti coloniale se
renforce
les autorités se défendent en affirmant
que les gendarmes ont légitimement
ouvert le feu l'usagé des armes a été
déployé par les forces de l'ordre dans
un cadre parfaitement légale mais
personnel se sont trouvés dans un cas de
légitime défense collective caractérisée
et c'est en vertu des dispositions de
l'article 104 du code pénal que la force
des armes a été détruit et une terrible
nouvelle se répand le jour des obsèques
dilma ni un autre cadavre vient d'être
retrouvé sur une plage de basse pointe
il s'agit du corps d'un ouvrier maçon de
19 ans georges marie louise un jeune
homme qui n'avait plus donné signe de
vie depuis sa participation aux
affrontements contre les gendarmes
un cadavre manifestement mutilé diront
des témoins affirmation contredite par
le rapport d'autopsié
et les circonstances de la mort de
georges marie denise ne seront jamais
élucidé pas plus que nous serons
inquiéter les gendarmes qui ont tiré à
la saint valentin le 19 février un
accord sera finalement conclu entre
patrons et syndicats
une journée de travail dans la banane
sera désormais payé 35 francs 50
une victoire au goût amer la
responsabilité peut être indirecte du
fait qu'ils n'ont peut-être jamais tenu
compte des revendications salariales des
ouvriers agricoles
chaque année d'une marche commémorative
est organisé sur le trajet des ouvriers
agricoles de 74 entre le laurent et
basse-pointe 46 ans après le drame de
challes vahid reste une plaque est une
chanson pour raviver le souvenir
dillmann y seriez
j'ai failli me coûter sa qui passe fait
c'était un février 1974